movies have a magical way of making it
all seem so believable from blood and
monsters to cash lots and lots of fake
cash so if you've ever wondered how it
all works we've got the answers ready
action in movies like carry blood comes
by the buckets perfecting that red gooey
mess took a long time and several
different recipes this is the story of
how fake movie blood is made
[Music]
back before film and TV a simple red
handkerchief on stage symbolized blood
but it was kind of boring so some
theatres up the ante by boiling a bug
known for its red pigment they used the
Cochin you bug because it creates red
dye when black and white movies came
along pigment didn't matter so Hollywood
simplified things by using chocolate
syrup then in the 1930s when black and
white movies turned to color Hollywood
needed a new blood trick enter John Tyne
Gate a retired pharmacist living in
England he concocted the most realistic
looking blood yet called Kensington gore
using a combination of mostly golden
syrup food coloring cornflour and water
the most famous of the blood recipes
though comes from a man named dick Smith
he came up with something on par with a
Julia Child recipe the catch his recipe
was poisonous one ingredient Kodak photo
flow is deadly when consumed so people
started replacing the poison with
creamer and other items that won't kill
you today a lot of the fake blood you
see on screen is computer-generated but
if you want to be legit it should be
poison or bugs
[Music]
this is affiliate
we think and that billion dollars
belongs to r.j. Rappaport and he's
considered the king of cash fake cash
okay
king of fake cash my name is rich r.j.
Rappaport and I'm the president of our
gr props just a few years ago actually
it was nine years ago
oh sorry nine years ago RJ R props was
born it's a full-service prop house but
its specialty is cash think cash and
there's only a few people who can
legally make it and RJ is one of them we
work with 50 cent Kendrick Lamar Lil
Wayne Fat Joe Young Dolph and that's
just to name a few RJ's prop money has
been used in over 175 feature films
television shows and music videos and he
devoted three full years to perfecting
that crisp green paper we call money
prop money
and we went down a long path and working
with the Secret Service and learning all
the laws to make sure that everyone that
uses it it will be legal for them and
it'll look fantastic but for those who
don't follow the rules they could wind
up in big trouble there is a rash of
arrests people were just literally
jailed because they were using prop
money that looked too real and I said to
myself I'm not gonna touch this unless I
know I'm doing it legally alongside the
Secret Service RG created two different
styles of prop money one that is printed
on both sides and is perfect for that
classic bank robbery scene the other
kind is so close to the real deal it can
only be printed on one side otherwise it
could end up in circulation it's
designed for the classic money shot aka
the close-up it's a tough business we
all work hard in it and prompt money
especially it's not easy yeah sounds
like it thanks RJ for keeping fake money
real for 31 years I have been acting in
major motion pictures in TV series but
you may not recognize my face I'm Doug
Jones I am an actor
[Music]
I got into acting out of a need almost
to be validated and it was at Ball State
University that I discovered the art of
mine it's a very visual form of
communication and entertainment little
did I know that this would be early
training ground for the career that I
was going to have lay in later years I
had no idea after moving out to
Hollywood land in March of 1985 and
thinking okay now's the time to pursue
this acting thing my fourth booking was
for a McDonald's campaign that got me
kind of hooked into oh he's that tall
skinny guy who wears stuff and moves
well in it and doesn't complain while
doing so my first feature film was
Batman Returns I got that audition
because of my contorted legs and the
credits that says thin clown which kind
of kind of self descriptive isn't it I
have been in over a hundred and fifty
productions that would include
everything from feature films like hocus
pocus Hubley one Hellboy to the Golden
Army the fawn in Pan's Labyrinth was a
page turning a career moment for me
Fantastic Four rise of the Silver Surfer
I played the Silver Surfer Star Trek
discovery as commander Saru and most
recently the shape of water so when
asked about how long does it make up
take it depending on the creature it can
be anything from a suit going on zipping
up the back or a makeup that is applied
you from head to toe for instance as
commander surreal and Star Trek
discovery it's around two hours a day
which is mercifully short flip-side
would be an Abe Sapien from the Hellboy
movies so that's one of the longer ones
that took seven hours a day wearing
rubber bits that gets everything that
you think it would be it is hot as they
want it to be
is heavier than you want it to be it's
more isolating than you want it to be
you can't always make it access to your
naughty bits to go P if you want why go
through all of this makeup application
the time that it takes you can create
monsters with the effects now I think
people like to watch other people so
even if that person is playing a monster
they want to connect with a human's
interpretation and performance of that
monster it's old-school cinema magic I
kind of get the best of both worlds when
it comes to being a public celebrity the
bigger movies I've been in and bigger
things that I'm known for I look like
this and them on the street
I'm just the tall skinny guy that's a
gift now that I'm in a movie like the
shape of water with 13 Oscar nominations
I'm getting recognized in public a
little bit more but it's still not to
the point where I where I have people
hiding in my bushes hoping to get a
snapshot of me topless that's not
happening again
[Music]
this story begins in California to be
more specific here in an unspecified
studio lot this is the story of a TV
producer a physicist and the man who
brought them both together that's Wendy
I'm one of the co producers of Marvel's
agent Carter in 2015
ABC released the show agent Carter about
a secret agent working in the late 1940s
in season two they debuted a character
named Jason Wilkes Jason is a scientist
who works at isodyne energy and a
science character needs to sound like a
real scientist kind of like this Peggy
enters to find Howard at the chalkboard
with books lambda divided by MC except
we can't calculate an without an
accurate reading a real mess no mess no
wavelength hey peg you're back so you
need to write science e dialogue write
sciency stuff on the chalkboard and have
a science e looking lab but you don't
have any science writers on staff no
unfortunately we do not so what did you
do
we called our friends up at the National
Academy of Sciences IV change it's Rick
this is Rick hey I'm Rick I work at the
National Academy of Sciences we connect
scientists and engineers with people in
Hollywood people like Wendy yeah we
connected her with Clifford hi my name
is Clifford Johnson I am a professor in
the physics and astronomy department at
USC so it goes like this
Rick pears Clifford with Wendy and they
work together to bring real science into
TV shows yeah yeah yeah for example I
got an email one time saying so how do
you build an atomic bomb and I had to
sort of help them with that it was a lot
of fun Rick's team has a database with a
lot of scientists in it over 2,000 and
they've worked on some major blockbuster
films
Iron Man two and three the Avengers age
of Ultron Batman vs Superman star trek
into darkness mission impossible 5 films
a narrative have been inspiring people
since the 19th century to go out and do
great things and build great things
we're not trying to be the accuracy
police we're not fact checkers per se
what our goal is is to inspire more
scientists characters and better science
in mainstream media projects and that's
the story about the hotline for
scientists in Hollywood that is changes
right I'm Jen Kindergarten CEO of
king-sized bows incorporated and welcome
to my Vulcan 'dom
we're in the joy business we make
special occasions special I have to say
that our most popular bow is our
signature monarch fold the red and
silver one
the Lexus commercials that we've had the
privilege of doing for the last eight
years has really drawn attention to the
multi loop bows
we're the only ones in the United States
who actually make those bows we make
them out of a variety of fabrics and
textures and those are the ones that
people are most interested in there's a
whole bow language that most people
don't speak but there are definitely
differences of opinions about how many
loops how long the tails should be and
whether there's a V cut or an angled cut
we are pleased to be in every showroom
from Ferrari to the mini to the Ford to
BMW now we've found that customers
really expect to keep the bow when they
buy the car they want to drive away with
the bow
you'd be surprised where people have put
bows it's not just on top of a car any
place that you want to say look at me
look at me it can be on a bicycle or a
surfboard or skis on a gate on the top
of your house at a pinnacle
once you put a bow on it it's a present
[Music]